[Musique]
étudiante en biologie en cinéma mathilde
jessica et mélanie ont pratiquement fait
leurs horaires de cours en fonction dès
lundi mais lundi depuis deux ans on lève
pour la banque alimentaire avec le
camion de location
ces directions moisson montréal pour
rassembler aliments frais et autres
denrées sont empreintes de sa fête de
140 leur liste d'épicerie sert à nourrir
de 150 à 200 étudiants de l'université
de montréal
chaque semaine les i ce moment c'est la
glace la crème glacée va rester là
parce qu'il n'ya pas de frigo dans le
coin de la cafétéria du pavillon jean
brillant qu'occupe la banque alimentaire
tous les lundis après midi plusieurs
bénéficiaires sont aussi des bénévoles
l'initiative née d'une poignée
d'étudiants en philosophie il ya quatre
ans mobilise aujourd'hui une vingtaine
de paires de bras la gagne très l'fun
puis ça fait bien d'aider les gens puis
si ça nous rassure côté alimentaire pour
nous si on sait qu'on pourra manger on
pourrait bien manger aussi la demande
est triplé en trois ans
plus de 1200 étudiants inscrits à la
banque alimentaire de l'université
ils sont allés au moins une fois chacun
doit prouver son statut d'étudiant
régulier et ses revenus vraiment le
logement etc une grosse part de mon
budget plus les dépenses notamment au
moins de septembre tout ce qui est
réinstallation achats de livres etc
c'est vrai que ça vient vraiment creuser
le budget ils ont mené une chose à payer
à la vie est ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui
on les études d'un téléphone cellulaire
lyon et on l'a vite ils ont besoin de
mener pour être intégrés dans la société
et sera un des premiers postes départ ce
qui va être sacrifié un des postes qui
est élastique c'est la bouffe des deux
tiers sont des étudiants étrangers
souvent la précarité est résolu par le
contact
sauf que les étudiants qui ne sont pas
de montréal où les étrangers qui n'ont
pas de ce contact là au québec se
retrouve dans une impasse
le retour au doctorat est diminuer les
revenus des sept étudiants pensent
consacre à nos études alors le budget
est plus serré ça nous aide beaucoup
en même temps c'est de la solidarité
étudiante facile d'établir le portrait
de la précarité sur les quarante cinq
mille étudiants réguliers de
l'université de montréal plus de 14
millions des prêts et bourses du
gouvernement et 400 des bourses pour le
soutien économique en 2017
les banques alimentaires du québec ont
constaté que 4% de leurs utilisateurs
étaient des étudiants universitaires ici
à nourrice des tati radio canada
montréal